et l'une des conséquences de cette crise
sanitaire dont on parle peu la dette des
entreprises qui ne cesse de grimper dans
quelle mesure ces d'entraînement
menace-t-il la reprise espérée l'année
prochaine est ce une bombe à retardement
pour l'économie on en parle tout de
suite avec notre économiste jacques
sapir bonsoir jacques et merci d'être
avec nous bonsoir stéphanie alors est-il
vrai jacques que les entreprises ont
accumulé beaucoup de dettes avec
l'épidémie et que cela pourrait
compromettre même la reprise
oui c'est fini c'est tout à fait évident
et il faut comprendre une chose c'est
que les entreprises françaises voient
évidemment leur endettement s'accroître
avec la crise sanitaire
il ya des chaînes d'endettement qui sont
en train de se constituer par rapport
aux fournisseurs par rapport aux sous
traitants mais aussi par rapport aux
banques alors c'est qu'en partie le
résultat de la politique de soutien du
gouvernement qui a privilégié d'une
certaine manière les crédits les crédits
garantis aux subventions
l'important dans cette histoire c'est
que le chiffre d'affaires des
entreprises est en train de baisser et
en tous les cas ne retrouvant pas le
niveau de 2019 et bien évidemment ça ne
permettra pas aux entreprises de
rembourser ou ne serait-ce que de faire
face financièrement à cette dette donc
oui effectivement il y à bien un risque
sur la reprise à venir
alors jacques comment l'endettement des
entreprises at il progressé justement
ces derniers temps c'est un cet
endettement s'est énormément accrue
on a aujourd'hui les chiffres qui sont
donnés par la banque de france et on
voit de ce point de vue là que
l'endettement a augmenté d'environ 10%
en quelques mois de février à août de
cette année donc oui c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait considérable 10% de plus
d'endettement et c'est d'autant plus
considérable que le chiffre d'affaires
des entreprises
évidemment n'a pas progressé il a même
régressé il s'est contractée de manière
extrêmement importante avec le premier
et maintenant avec le 2ème confinement
donc ça veut dire
que la capacité des entreprises à
rembourser leurs dettes
c'est en réalité dégradé et ça c'est
évidemment quelque chose de très
inquiétant alors quelles sont les
entreprises qui se sont le plus endetté
pas c'est pas étonnant ce sont
essentiellement les petites et moyennes
entreprises ce qu'on appelle les pme il
faut comprendre que dans le confinement
qu'on avait subi au printemps dès qu'on
est en train à nouveau de subir mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans le
premier confinement le premier et femmes
oui le premier mois les grandes
entreprises se sont précipités sur les
aides offertes par le gouvernement mais
ensuite on voit que ce sont ce qu'on
appelle les pme et les pays autrement
dit les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire qui se sont massivement
endettés et et qui ont continué en fait
de s'endetter pratiquement jusqu'au mois
de juillet ce qui fait que le stock de
dette s'est fortement accrue et
justement dans des entreprises
que ce soit les pme où que ce soit les
outils dont la capacité à faire face à
ses frais financiers et bien n'est pas
du tout évidente
jacques que cela est dû à la politique
de l'état en partie en partie seulement
bien entendu la première cause de cet
endettement
c'est la contraction de l'activité
économique que les entreprises ont subi
d'abord avec la crise sanitaire dans son
ensemble et puis avec évidemment les
confinements mais la décision politique
de l'état c'est une décision politique
de jouer essentiellement sur la
dimension des crédits des crédits
garantis et vous savez la france comme
d'ailleurs d'autres pays d'europe 1
comme le royaume-uni l'italie comme
l'allemagne
mais justement ce n'est pas la situation
que l'on connaît
en hausse très aux états unis la france
a décidé de faire jouer à ce crédit donc
aux banques le rôle principal dans la
politique de soutien aux entreprises
c'est ce qui a permis en fait que se
constitue un stock de dette tout à fait
un
questionnant et on peut se demander
aujourd'hui si en poussant les
entreprises à s'endetter
le gouvernement n'avait pas fait à
l'époque le pari d'une reprise rapide
or la prolongation de l'épidémie montre
que ce pari est à l'évidence perdu et
jacques pourquoi pensez-vous que cela
risque précisément de compromettre la
relance il ya deux raisons la première
c'est évidemment que des entreprises qui
auraient pu autrement survivre à leur
endettement
face à ce surcroît d'endettement
engendrée par la crise sanitaire là ne
pourront pas justement survivre vont se
trouver condamné avait fait ça c'est le
premier point mais il ya aussi le cas
des entreprises qui vont survivre on
espère qu'elles seront les plus
nombreuses donc les entreprises et
qu'ils vont survivre elles vont devoir
faire un effort particulier pour
rembourser leurs dettes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un effort
particulier c'est à dire que dame d'une
part elles vont évidemment augmenter
leurs prix et d'autre part elles vont
sacrifier l'investissement ce qui en
réalité va compromettre leur survie dans
une économie qui est largement au
compétitive et largement ouverte à la
compétition internationale
donc on voit bien que sur les deux
points l'économie française va perdre du
terrain
la reprise sera nécessairement moins
forte soit parce qu'un certain nombre
d'entreprises ont fait faillite soit
parce que les entreprises vont baisser
largement leurs investissements et donc
il y à l'évidence un problème pour la
reprise
en plus nous avons aussi le problème et
banque alors en quoi est ce que les
banques seront justement concerné dans
cette affaire si vous voulez la baisse
du chiffre d'affaires des entreprises
signifie donc qu'une partie des dettes
qu'elles ont ne seront pas remboursables
en tous les cas ne pourront pas être
remboursées dans le délai qui était
prévu c'est ce qu'on appelle en langage
bancaires des prêts non performants
autrement dit des créances douteuses
alors quand il y à une montée des
créances douteuses et yvette absolument
l'évidence
on aura une montée extrêmement
importante de ses créances à partir du
premier semestre de l'année prochaine
donc quand on a une montée des créances
douteuses qu'est ce qui se passe bien
les banques sont obligées par la
législation de faire des provisions
autrement dit de réduire leur capacité à
faire des crédits et donc les banques
vont réduire les prêts qu'elle faisait
normalement aux entreprises et aux
ménages
or le problème c'est qu'une grosse
partie de ce qu'on appelle le capital
circulant autrement dit de l'argent avec
lequel on achète des marchandises on
achète des stocks etc
cet argent est empruntée donc les
entreprises feu avaient recours d'une
certaine manière au crédit bancaire
là elles ne pourront pas l'avoir où
elles seront obligées de demander
nettement moins d'argent à ses banques
ce qui va évidemment avoir un effet
dépressif important sur la reprise et
c'est peut-être là que se situe une
véritable bombe à retardement pour la
reprise française donc jacques pour vous
quand on se focalise sur la dette
publique celle des états ont fait une
erreur oui oui parce que la dette
publique elle peut se régler de manière
beaucoup plus simple en fait c'est le
gonflement de la dette privée et qui est
réellement inquiétant parce que la
situation financière des entreprises
c'est en réalité ce qui va déterminer de
l'activité économique de demain vous
savez si on doit sortir de cette crise
sanitaire avec des entreprises qui
croule sous le montant de leur dette
d'une dette qu'elles ne pourront pas
pour un certain nombre d'entre elles
rembourser et bien évidemment la reprise
qui aurait dû venir après la dépression
que nous connaissons en 2020 et bien
cette reprise pourrait être très
durablement compromise je pense que le
gouvernement doit prendre conscience de
ce fait et doit s'il veut éviter
justement que la reprise
il n'est pas lieu eh bien il doit agir
maintenant ou plus merci jacques de quoi
pas vraiment de remonter le moral mais
merci quand même merci à vous jacques
saint-pierre